[Música]
y vamos ahora a repasar toda la
actualidad económica nos acompaña ya en
el estudio Daniela Blandón bienvenida
Muchas gracias Daniela lo decíamos en
los noticieros hoy concluyó una de las
mayores operaciones bancarias de la
historia en Suiza Claro que sí Rosa Pues
el banco
completada la adquisición de su rival
que empezó en marzo cuando la crisis de
liquidez de la entidad hizo tener un
efecto dominó a escala global la compra
se cerró por unos 3.320 millones de
dólares y esto valió es una serie de
quejas por considerarla muy baja esa
cifra ahora el primer y el segundo banco
de Suiza forman una misma entidad con un
valor de Mercado de 1,6 billones de
dólares entre ambas entidades empleaban
a unas 120.000 personas o van a emplear
a unas 120.000 personas en todo el mundo
pero uvs ya anunció un recorte de
plantilla Aunque Todavía no he dicho a
quienes específicamente estaría dejando
sin trabajo bueno seguro que es una
noticia que muchos trabajadores esperan
Daniela por otro lado también lo
avanzábamos hace unos minutos y es que
Open ahí una de las firmas líderes en
Inteligencia artificial hizo un llamado
a la calma claro el ceo del fabricante
del famoso chat de gpt respaldado por
Microsoft terminó en Japón una Gira
Mundial para convencer a los diferentes
gobiernos y comunidades de las bondades
de la Inteligencia artificial y aunque
reconoce que comenzó su viaje con algo
de pesimismo ahora es más optimista
sobre lo que viene para la industria
algunos trabajos desaparecerán pero no
creo que vaya a tener el impacto en el
empleo que la gente Espera a medida que
se puedan automatizar procesos cada vez
más grandes eso liberará a las personas
para trabajar a un nivel más alto
ahora vemos programadores de
computadoras que usan estas herramientas
y son dos o tres veces más productivos
que antes y luego surge la pregunta de
qué sucede cuando no son dos o tres
veces más productivos sino 20 o 30 veces
y la respuesta creo Es que el mundo
recibe más y mejores cosas Rosa Y es que
lo hemos comentado varias veces en este
espacio que los reguladores están
esforzando por adaptar las reglas y
también crear nuevas pautas para regir
el uso de la Inteligencia artificial ya
que está generando a la vez entusiasmo
pero también temor sobre su potencial
después de haber anunciado que
organizaría la primera Cumbre
internacional sobre este tema en otoño
próximo Reino Unido dijo que quiere
liderar esta apuesta a nivel mundial
las posibilidades son extraordinarias
pero debemos hacerlo y lo haremos con
seguridad sé que la gente está
preocupada los mismos Pioneros de la
Inteligencia artificial nos advierten
sobre las formas en que estas
tecnologías podrían socavar nuestros
valores y libertades hasta los riesgos
más extremos de todos y es por eso que
liderar en Inteligencia artificial
también significa liderar en su
seguridad
y Daniela y también recordemos Estados
Unidos a Unión Europea anunciaron un
borrador No de código de conducta bueno
esperamos a ver cómo avanza toda esta
idea de regulación pero las
preocupaciones sobre Inteligencia
artificial también llegan al mundo de la
cultura lo hemos también hablado acá
porque hoy ha salido Internacional del
doblaje en España Esta es una seña de
identidad desde los años 30 que mueve
unos 100 millones de euros al año y
emplea a unas 5.000 personas pero
precisamente la irrupción de esta
Inteligencia artificial preocupa a Los
profesionales del doblaje por posibles
impactos y hay que recordar que también
lo han hecho en otros actores de la
industria en Hollywood se han quejado
por lo mismo están en huelga los
libretistas de de Hollywood por esta
misma razón los actores también amenazan
con ir a huelga por lo mismo ya están en
negociaciones en este momento de todas
maneras vamos a mostrar las voces de
esta historia en España con nuestra
corresponsal en Madrid Marina colorado
ensayan para hacer las próximas Voces
del doblaje en España y Luis ecquerra es
quien los guía por este arte que ha
cambiado mucho en los últimos años desde
la pandemia por ejemplo los guiones
impresos se quedaron obsoletos
preparaba tres guiones por película por
documental y ahora todo lo tenemos Ya
digitalizado no esto es lo que van
trayendo lo que es o sea lo que trae y
lo que conlleva las nuevas tecnologías
en este caso pues bueno pues mucho mejor
una nueva tecnología está poniendo en
alerta a la industria la Inteligencia
artificial Pablo Fernández cofundador de
varias empresas de ia asegura que los
actores no desaparecerán pero sí tendrán
que reinventarse probablemente los el
trabajo de los dobladores a futuro no
será repetir o leer lo que pone en un
texto sino será dar instrucciones a la
Inteligencia artificial de quiero que me
dobles esto sonando como este actor no
Entonces pasas de ser un instrumento a
ser un director de Orquesta
Raúl se prepara para reunirse con los
directores de doblaje de videojuegos que
forman parte de adoma sindicato de
actores de doblaje de Madrid que él
preside son parte de la iniciativa y un
aire voice arest
este grupo global de sindicatos de
actores pide transparencia en los
contenidos generados por Inteligencia
artificial y una compensación por
derechos de autor el resultado que va a
dar va a ser porque ha cogido la
interpretación
de pues x decenas cientos o miles de
actores y actrices las Ha deformado
hasta que ninguno sea reconocible y se
inventa un timbre según los parámetros
que le estén dando es una simulación
hecha con un montón de interpretaciones
que pertenecen a alguien
autores invisibles que temen ser
sustituidos y que levantan la voz y
esperan que las únicas iniciales ia en
la industria del doblaje sean las de
inteligencia artística
Dani cambiamos de tema porque Francia
muestra mucho interés en el litio de
Chile No pues en este país sudamericano
el gobierno Está tratando de impulsar la
producción de este mineral clave en la
fabricación de baterías para vehículos
eléctricos su objetivo es atraer
inversiones siempre y cuando los
proyectos tengan mayoría Estatal es una
condición Que no suele atraer mucho a
los inversionistas pero Francia sí se
interesó
estamos en chile para discutir sobre las
asociaciones que podemos establecer para
contribuir a esta Aventura minera del
litio en conjunto con las necesidades
europeas y particularmente francesas
tenemos una oferta tecnológica
totalmente diferente gracias a firmas
como hermet o como Geo Lite tenemos la
posibilidad de extraer litio reduciendo
considerablemente el consumo de agua
Rosa y este interés no es para menos
chile es el segundo mayor productor de
litio del mundo solamente superado por
Australia otros países que también
producen son china Argentina y Brasil y
Francia está apostándole a la
fabricación de baterías eléctricas en
megafábricas locales para lo cual es
litio sería muy importante bueno y
veremos como influencia en esto la gira
de Wonder Legend no precisamente
Daniela rápidamente la cifra del día 25
mil millones de dólares en esta cifra
está valorado el Imperio del
multimillonario filántro George soros
que acaba de entregarlo a su hijo menor
Alexander El joven de 37 años dijo que
es más político que su padre y que va a
aumentar el apoyo al derecho al voto y
también al aborto Sólo dos es el creador
de Open society foundations que destina
cientos de millones de dólares a grupos
de defensa de Derechos Humanos pues
muchas gracias Daniela nos vemos Ya que
una hora aquí nos vemos con más economía